hello and welcome to a new Fresh episode
of trash Tuesday it's a little bit crazy
today
dare I say there's some After Dark
Energy
because we've been amongst each other
and we're a little too comfortable we've
all reached the same cycle I've had a
completely stand up it's going to be
real bloody on this couch well I'm
ovulating baby shoot him into my mouth
wait is that why I feel like you really
need to be a lesbian because I'm like I
I think you have sperm to give me yeah I
do and you're drunk I keep it in my
cheek I've been drinking the simply
spiked who took my mango peach away
the police
father
laughs
[Music]
this show is sponsored by betterhelp let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday order
your THC products from mood today for 20
off your first order and free gummies go
to hellomood.com and use promo code
trash Tuesday that's
hellomood.com promo code trash Tuesday
for 20 off your order and free gummies
hi slugs it's August we're all slugs I'm
wearing glasses in hot pink and I am a
stand-up comedian and you can see me
this month in Oxnard and then I will be
in DC Boston Madison Wisconsin San Diego
Detroit Chicago San Jose Irvine get
tickets at astronice.com
hey sluggies happy Tuesday
um you can see me in Philadelphia August
11th and 12th I'll be in Calgary August
27th at The Great Outdoors Comedy
Festival with Andrew Schultz I'm going
to be in San Francisco at Cobbs on
September 15th and 16th Austin Texas in
October I also have a bunch of dates
that have not gone up yet you can go to
annieleterman.com shows they will be
there now
foreign
[Music]
how's everybody feeling today I feel
good yeah I feel good
um I feel
um
can I tell you guys something I hailed
really hard for no reason okay I want to
tell you something I did this weekend or
this week I went to a Dodgers game hell
yeah Annie oh don't you it was so fun
that's we're gonna have to take her oh
no I'm gonna it was so fun Dodger games
are it it was so fun thank you Annie I
had a blast and I figured out how to
smuggle mushrooms in
oh okay you know how they have you you
can only bring your bag clear bag they
go through your stuff yeah you can't
bring in purses or anything I was
wearing a swimsuit top and you know how
they have the Pat the whole for the
padding doing you just put them in that
wait do you eat mushrooms like that just
dried not even these were in no these
ones were in um I love how you think it
can only be dry or candy in the capsules
oh I'm doing capsules because I will say
that I was at a party recently and
people on mushrooms are so much more fun
than drug people a man just came up to
me and was like me and he came to me and
Dave and was like Hey I just want to
introduce myself we found out he's on
mushrooms of course but I'm like I love
this people want to be my friend when
they're on severe drugs hallucinating so
when you're on shrooms like it makes you
more social
the thing with shrimps is it really
depends on the dose you never really
know it's it's hard I didn't end up
taking the mushrooms I was I just had to
completely
just there for the game sober yeah I was
completely sobering with my friend
Michael dare and his girlfriend Rosie uh
Josh Potter and his lady friend Lauren
and Todd was there any good food we had
a we got a helmet full of nachos okay
that's good tell me how you feel about
that
we waited in line we took we got the
wrong line with the senile woman it was
like uh the most I have never seen
anyone take longer in a line in my
entire life every line was like it would
be like people would come like 55
minutes after me and they were going I
watched most of the game like my neck
hurts from looking up at the screen
watching the game I mean it was it was
wild how long it took and then we get up
there and we hadn't discussed this yet
Todd goes by the way Todd will be with
me in every line like I'm not going
alone it's either Todd's alone or I'm
with him and I prefer to be with him
together we will miss this game but
we're waiting in line and we get the the
helmet of nachos and he goes do you want
chili on it and I want absolutely not
just is and he goes come on we waited
all this time for the chili so I go okay
the fire Rhea I had this morning I was
like Todd diarrhea you did this to me I
was burning it was rancid it was like
you did this to me wait that's you
called it fiorea I wish I'd point the
term but I've had so much experience
with hot lava diarrhea pouring out of my
ass man I've known a fire real for a
long time we were I was bideting so hard
on my ass like I was like I'm just gonna
do it at the same time while it's coming
out so it was like good and evil meeting
it was it was horrific oh my god when I
worked at Johnny Rockets and we would
make you'd shoot some Johnny Rockets out
chili cheese fries I gotta say chili and
like nachos or fries is so good but
nacho cheese for me is so pure like just
nachos it's just the like like I will
take gas station nachos over going to a
restaurant and having respect I want it
to be as cheese whizzy as possible she's
whizzy but just that liquid yes
community pool at the movies yes yes
you're purist yes the places where
you're definitely gonna get it wet
accidentally like yeah like yeah we're
not supposed to be eating for a half
hour and
um by the way
like you're the swimmer you're asking us
oh nothing's ever happened oh my God
just asked her what did you know she's
been taking a break uh a cramp break her
entire life from somebody okay so I've
always eaten large meals like when we go
on like like island hopping big meals
straight jump straight into the water
nothing has ever happened is that an
island hopping like it's a normal thing
I grew up doing that because there's 7
000 islands where I'm from that's all
you can do it's like hop on we haven't
been invited to one we can we uh if just
whatever like fantasy renting out the
community pool in Skokie and then you
teach me how to swim did not did no one
else thinks we're gonna can we go to the
cool Philippines yeah
have you ever did you ever do anything
like bad when you were a teenager did
you break rules and stuff
no nothing there was any sex tape there
was a sex tape there was a sex tape that
really breaking a rule except the law
but
the largest the child pornography law
the number one law I did some really
high risk like Behavior like I had some
problems I would hitch rides oh yeah
what the time wearing like the it I'm
like now that I'm like oh my God if I if
my daughter did this I would be having
panic attacks that's so 1970s of you
because my mom has talked about being in
situations where she has to like had to
in her younger years like leave a date
because the man was being inappropriate
and the only option then was to
hitchhike home like you could have been
killed I can't believe you did that's
how bad the date was she's like I got it
I might get murdered but I can't be here
it was with my dad
like because sometimes I had an MTA bus
pass
um and I sometimes I would miss the bus
and I'm like oh [__] the bus doesn't
come for another 20 minutes and I would
just like hit your ride and dudes it's
always dudes it stopped and I you know
my body was delivered safely and in one
piece but like I probably I must have
done that like at least 25 years because
also you're molested so you're like
you're doing higher risk behavior
constantly because they're like isn't
this normal this is normal to be
constantly almost dying we used to get
like fully naked in the car
we thought it was like funny to be naked
going through
um toll booths oh like with your friends
yeah it would be just a group of like
guys and girls just fully naked that
sounds really cool wait what are other
like rule breaking things well I was
thinking the thing I was thinking about
this is a little more Innocent but we
would always like go into the pool when
it was closed we would like hop into
like that's my dream it was really fun I
loved night meets night swim team meets
were the best
um being in a pool in the dark is like
the best oh that sounds so fun I've
dreamed of climbing over that gate and
going into that and watching everyone
else and being in the she she broke in
to go to the kiddie pool I have a very
specific type of nighttime pool trauma
that I don't think anyone can relate to
unless like you grow up in the
Philippines but when they would turn on
the lights at abiliana's where we used
to swim at night it would attract all of
these bugs and these flying giant flying
ants and they would all swarm into the
pool so one of my weird little the first
time she went into the pool that
happened to her and we would all have to
like the bugs would then um find their
way underneath our Lycra suit and they
would bite us we had a lot of like bug
bites all over our body to have
something biting you that's under the
surface that is yeah and it's not like
we could stop and be like hey there's
bugs in my suit like you just had to
keep going and it's such a weird
specific thing can I just yeah you have
really sexy hands I do I know you know
finally she knows something
no like Korean women have stopped me my
whole life and have been like like they
always want to stop and see and I
noticed that I don't know if I've said
this before on here but when I was in a
scene with Margot Robbie on dollface the
first thing I noticed about Margot
Robbie was her hands were so sexy I
can't believe you got near a Margot
Robbie can I know they allow Junior
and you have was security like right
behind the camera
looking at me
like average hot girl height like
probably like five seven ish I think we
can Google that but I I remember
five seven five eight maybe this is five
two she was so tall
I think that you're attracted to my
hands at the moment because my nails are
cut really short it's very masculine
it's like a it's like a sexy woman yeah
they're they're you want to be fingered
by these I do I actually just want to
look at them I think I have a hand
fetish
I do too for men I do I really do I look
at Men's hands all the time you're out
of the running again I'm not doing nails
for a while these are so bad right now
you're not doing nails I just ripped my
nails off and then was like I hate
sitting in the salon it's so painful
that I'm like maybe I'm taking him a
beat but I will say if if I do get nails
if you see with nails what I really want
to go back to getting matte nude yeah I
feel a little bit like a robot alien I
like that I want short again I can't but
then I wouldn't do nails right you would
just do your well mine just started I
bite them and stuff if I don't have
nails on them
um you know what I just realized about
myself after 38 years is
it is almost impossible for me to flirt
with someone I actually like when I
don't like someone the ease at which I
can flirt is like it's incredible like I
can look at a guy and say the wildest
[__] and in the most flirtatious way
like and it's organized
they're like wait what did women do
and so like but if I like someone and if
I'm attracted to them I will avoid eye
contact and when they talk to me you're
like shy I start to stutter and I'm just
like I it's I'm fully embarrassed bro
literally when I talk about the night I
met Dave
the first sentence is always oh I saw a
guy I thought was hot and then I hid
from him
my first into I'll never forget seeing
him being that guy so cute have to hide
I did not want I was I have the same
thing it's like at a random house party
like what is that took you to the party
it was me and uh Lauren Greenberg went
oh okay yeah it was like he does know
the cool people it was a group well I
think I we it was Angela's party okay
um but there was like a multiple
birthday party Angela knows the cool
people too yeah and um not that anyone
in this story is cool me or Dave
but yeah like that instinct to hide from
someone you view is attractive it's like
oh I I'm gonna [__] it up so I may as
well not go near them right I don't know
if that's what it is or like being like
afraid of like rejection rejection
rejection or like what if it works out I
mean maybe but I it's I am a fool like I
cannot formulate sentences
um I'm just like kind of stumbling over
myself I'm really awkward kind of stiff
and rigid won't do eye contact like at
all like I become like just a a kid
almost but so if I'm if you're a guy and
I've flirted with you with ease I don't
like you so sorry it's so sad for you
it's so sad like if there's so many like
hands that are like uncuffing
yeah but you know what I mean you can
wink at somebody you don't like like you
do so many things I just knew because I
was friends with Todd before we were
like romantic and I just when I started
have a crush on him I could not stop
laughing like he would say stuff and I
would be like doubled over like crying
laughing and then I was like stunting I
made him I think I told you guys this I
made him he said something
there was something about like I was
like teasing him about banging his dad
or something I don't know how it got
there but I was like who do you bang and
it was like I don't know why it was so
funny but um so then I went on his
Facebook and I found a picture of his
actual Dad I've never told him and I and
I had shown him this like really like
ridiculous dick pic I got ones and I
took the dick from the dick pic and I
put it on Todd and I photoshopped him
like penetrating his father
I sent it to him like a hundred times in
a row
you are supposed to be with the guy who
has lizards I just want you to know
you're in the right place
mother now guys the skink loves me they
resonate with my rap my gravelly voice
you are in the right place I have my
voice sounds like their skin look
they love me they love me
oh God but yup that's so funny to me how
you just
I mean that any other person would have
been like what is this girl doing but
then he's like I can't tell if she likes
me and then he was like his friends were
like she likes you she's just sent you
like a hundred like Honestly though like
if you had done that to me like when we
first met nothing it would be funnier to
me like that's exactly how I want people
to befriend me like go so over the top
like obnoxiously inappropriate and
that's how I'll feel the most
comfortable with you it's not like I met
his dad or anything
his dad I just went on Facebook and
found it and I love it the hard thing
you did when I first met you yeah you
are over the top you want to see my tits
why was that both of our things we
thought okay that's actually so damning
of me wait I did that for both of you in
the Green Room yeah you were like you
want to see my boobs because I wanted to
see yours yeah yours I just pulled out
yeah it was a fast one I knew I was like
I've heard of her I know we have the
same we have the same manager we're the
same people just looked a little
different wait I have a question and I
know my answer but I want to know your
guyses what do you think is like the
hottest profession a guy can have or
even just one really hot one that comes
to mind
editor oh
is that not so helpful
honestly dated one it's great the lower
the number one I was like oh my God I
got my Clips this is great oh wait
unlimited Clips
um
fisherman
super hot to me
um construction worker yeah super like
base not basic like uh like blue collars
the color is really hot for me I want to
say I never thought this before and it's
not for the reasons that you're gonna
think but a chef
because there's something about a man
that is in a hot kitchen sweaty are you
talking about carmy who's that from the
bear I did watch the first 30 minutes or
the first like he's he can get it yeah
Army can get it in all directions in
every hole he's part of this for sure
he's recently divorced the doctor is he
he's never gonna go for me but also
I know stop like there's something about
how focused they have to be on their art
of making food like they're so
distracted and they're cokeheads I love
that about that so but chefs are angry
artists right like yes yeah Todd and I
we have a riddle where we go which came
first the Coke or the cook cook or the
coke the Coker the cook did they did
being attracted to Coke make them chefs
or did um
did being in the kitchen make them cook
you know who the hottest Chef is though
who you guys know who Kristen Kish is no
yes oh she is I've never seen from are
you talking about from um Top Chef yeah
yeah she's she is freaking gorgeous and
in person even like just perfection
every Asian that's ever existed well she
did our show
Asians all I'm like always so like I I
just know I can name drop you and meet
any Asians
well the la Asian scene I feel like is a
little bit like it's so good too yeah
you know what's better than a name drop
when you drop finally dropped the tattoo
but wait there's something I have this
like weird fantasy of honestly like just
a guy like Dave like just in the kitchen
like really obsessed over his cooking
and then like yes and then I come in and
he's like get away and I'm like no
please and then you know what you say to
that what heard Jeff or yes chef that's
how you respond to him oh wait would you
get hotter I feel like you would like a
yes chef yes chef yes chef would you be
a sous chef
yeah wait what is that because you're
like the right hand man they tell you
yes I I have such right hand man I could
be the best at anything you take me out
you're you're single swimming right
[Laughter]
man honey oh both of us together would
kill us wait wait a second I'm not even
kidding you guys
I need this to happen because you've
never winged me not once we will hook up
I've been finding out I've been going
out in the wild by myself and like not
getting a lot of luck you need uh yes
and we can suss them out for you but I
need you to be like on some drugs
because I'm gonna be drinking you
actually don't need us to be on drugs
just a little bit because then I'll be
really insecure about the way I'm
behaving we're full we act like that
anyway do you remember you do a karaoke
party oh that's right
and singing the first two lines and
being like do I have to sing the whole
song like growing up with so much like
Gusto and so into it and then getting so
bored one second in but Dave just being
so angry and not hogging the karaoke
book yeah Dave any of my friends who are
like a little bit too much like me like
Jenna or roomie like he gets like he
treats them like mean he treats all of
your friends like that like a little
he's so nice to me though he's so nice
to you he is only ever nice to Cloud but
he's so mean that would make I would be
so triggered if he was being nice to
kalilah still to this yeah I'll never
forget that walk I'll never forget that
walk when Annie got Dave and Annie made
Dave laugh and then she brought up every
day for the next 10 years no I was
literally working with Sasha burn Cohen
like making Sasha Barnes laugh coming to
her house and be like Dave nothing
nothing Nathan Elder today laughed at my
joke not you
I'm like do you want to replay what they
said you know it's gonna really hurt
your feelings the way Dave greets me
when he sees me he his body does this he
goes
well because you take a lot of the heat
off of him until he's like maybe I'll
get a break from the anxiety but I kind
of feel the same way for him when I see
him I'm like Dave like it is so sweet to
see there's so I feel excited too I
don't know he's just a guy you're
excited to see
and then he just he slithers off into
like one of my skinks into a into a room
foreign
we've been through a lot things are
crazy we're getting back on track
everyone and sometimes in life we're
faced with tough choices and the path
forward isn't always clear whether
you're dealing with decisions around
your career your relationships or
anything else therapy helps you stay
connected to what you really want while
you navigate life so you can move
forward with confidence and excitement
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets and if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule they have a journal feature
that I love where I write down all my
heavy thoughts in between my sessions
and I bring up to my therapist on our
next appointment and all you have to do
is fill out a brief questionnaire to get
match the licensed therapist and switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge which I'm telling you guys is
such a godsend because it's not always
that easy to do let therapy be your map
with better help visit betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday today to get 10 off your
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday whether
you're new to cannabis
like Esther I'm the new and old Pro
there's no denying that many of the
products on the market seem iffy at best
and when you want to relax iffy is the
last way you want to feel mood puts an
end to guessing games it's 100 federally
legal Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC you can
have shipped straight to your door no
doctors no waiting just Affordable Legal
THC and for a limited time mood is
giving our listeners free Delta 9
gummies and 20 off your first order one
of my favorite things about mood is that
they have tested and tailored different
strains for specific moods so for
example they have energized they have
creative focused euphoric erotic sleepy
chill social body Soother and there's
plenty of versatile products that go
with whatever mood you're going for and
I find that to be very helpful and
however you like to take THC mood has
you covered it's great for both beginner
and Veteran users and they have great
tasting gummies classic flower can
medium pre-rolls and so much more all
and all of their products are regularly
third-party tested in DEA registered
labs and they're sourced from small
family farms and grown organically ready
for a good time without the guesswork
order your THC products for mood today
and for 20 off your first order and free
gummies go to hellomood.com and use
promo code trash Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your order and free gummies
bro the foolish what is the Bro thing no
because I'm like growing down but
something no no there's been a shift I'm
throwing down I can I tell you what it
is it's simply Spike
it's bringing her bro out can you
imagine though you and me at a party or
at a bar we we because like oh that
guy's kind of cute do you wanna do you
want me to know why I can't what because
you would leave the second and started
getting fun no no no no no no no five
minutes party I had five minutes with
her it reignited our friendship five
minutes we do it at night where Dave's
at a casino and then you have me all
night you and I claia goes oh that guy
really is cute you and I go right up to
him we [__] go hey bro we talked to
him we go hey bro
are we wearing backwards hats we got our
pants down below our ass we're like hey
bro
you like Eminem we just start rapping
we have a dance before we go up are you
are you both wearing Timbs we flash mob
them
we've gone from flashers to flash
mobbers and then guess what happens and
then guess what happens we eat cringes
so hard he runs into her exactly and
then they're like look at those buffoons
over there they're laughing we spread
and then this gorgeous goddess walks in
she's wearing her outfit from her her
karaoke okay but what about if you don't
agree with who I find attractive we
don't care it's not gonna happen no I
don't care
none of us will ever be attracted to the
same person but what if he's like you
know I can be an Ugo Chaser sometimes no
I don't we there's no ugly there's no
ugly that's true but I mean sometimes I
I go there's Vibes
I go real low
she walks in on our news
um mouth wide open a gape
um
if I think you're not gonna if you're
drinking and I think you're
off I'll help you okay what would you
say though
because I've done this before I've I
would I would before I help you steal
the deal I would I would make sure I
would go are you sure I'm seeing these
things there's a tech he's got a tick
but I like that stuff
terretsy
sign me up baby who doesn't like a
bobble head Max is do I tell you my
brother's trucks were like the what's up
really he must get along with most men
they're like okay dude we said hi okay
hello I've done this um I was in
um Barcelona and I was partying and I
was dancing
why is it when it's said appropriately
from someone that's not from there
I was in Barca barsa
um and I was I was dancing with my
friends and this guy came up behind me
and but I I knew that I had drank a good
amount of alcohol at this point so what
I did was I went to my friend who I knew
had drank the least and I brought like I
dragged this boy's head like I was this
I was like is he ugly I assumed he
didn't speak English for some reason he
just didn't look like a guy that spoke
English I'll say is he ugly and she was
like ah no no she's like she's like no
he's really cute he's really cute and so
I started making out with him like on
the dance floor right talk about can you
imagine if a guy said that like well I
grabbed her head I told her by the head
by the way she's wet as hell for some
reason I don't know why she's so into
this
but
I think it's the ugly and so we started
making out and then afterwards like the
party ended we go out to the we we head
out and then he was like in English he
was like where are you going after this
so he understood the whole transaction
and was fine with it
um his name's Adam he's turns out he's
from Morocco we're still friends to this
day never hooked up sins but I was so
embarrassed that I had like audibly
really out loud I mean like is he ugly
because he's ugly I won't kiss him tell
me he's [__] ugly or not like I was
saying out loud but he didn't he was
just like he thought it was funny he was
like oh this is pretty funny it actually
is really funny and Charming
that's hot well if she had been like
he's hideous it would have been
different and then my friend stepped on
a piece of glass and her foot exploded
in Blood and it was like a whole thing
that's always so annoying when your
friend gets like a seriousness oh my God
the night's over or it's just begun this
part I'm like oh we're about to be in
Bright Lights like oh
my God are you kidding me
and you're like it's so serious you're
like oh
my God does anyone have super glue it
Bobby he was actually really hot it was
like no one's fault you're like oh my
God you can't get mad at someone nobody
mad at you you're just like oh my God
but that's such a migraine
um and he wrote me a postcard for my
birthday from Morocco these guys who
think are still your friends are really
still holding out no this was in 2013.
this was a long time ago 10 years ago
they're not holding out anymore he
doesn't talk to me anymore he just send
you postcards I did see he's in the
states somewhere though I gotta go find
myself Dance Floor Daddy
wait can I tell you guys a DM that we
got on our trash today yeah
I've been propositioned by a guy at the
gym to bang his wife while he watches
immediately my mind went to I wonder
what Annie Esther and kalila would make
up the situation I'm so curious for
their thoughts and opinions and this is
from a guy getting hit on the gym is
always such a thing I'm always like I
just wanted to work out but can you
believe that like hey this guy walks up
this other guy he's like will you [__]
my wife oh it's a guy yeah it's guy on
guy a guy saying hey there was a girl
[__] my wife oh she's a he's a [__] then
um
it's different because I'm not a guy
like I just don't know would you do it
you think if I was yeah most guys would
really yeah I think so
it seems like so
diceye if she's a hot chick he was he
you know yeah you should be like bro
he's like
grabs her hair is she ugly oh it's a
special leg
I'm on steroids
my dick don't work can you [__] her but
here's the thing that's your gym that's
a place you go to a lot like you can't
like you cannot you can't [__] where you
live yeah you can't [__]
valid yeah it's not I I say no I don't
like that I used to a lot when I was
single on the road get approached in the
middle States I would always get
approached by couples and like sent DMS
of like women and I'm like I don't want
this yeah I'm not interested enjoy your
relationship and the worst I'm not a
unicorn exactly so I think that most
girls
at least for me if I know someone is
trying to unicorn me I couldn't run
faster in the opposite direction I think
that's one of the worst feelings okay so
my hinge and my Raya are both set to
girls only at the moment just because I
just I can meet the boys in the wild
whatever and especially on hinge when um
the girl is bisexual and you're like oh
she's really cute and maybe you're like
oh you want to like you know hit like or
whatever and then she posts a picture of
obviously her significant other on there
and you're just like
ill like you're just so icked out by the
guy that you immediately just like X Out
of the profile immediately yeah I can
only speak personally I'm not into it
but I can see other people thinking oh
yeah and thrilling and I know people
that like it but that's why they're
called unicorns because it is really so
rare to have a girl like be really into
that idea of being like the third wait
speaking of being the third there
actually was a a message about this wait
hold on
but also if you do it write us back
wait actually I need a second I just
have to go back there again we're gonna
switch gems how long is your membership
for they're hard to get out of crunch
are they I wouldn't if I was that guy
being prepositioned being propositioned
to have sex with that other guy's wife
like
there's something about him watching
that it's like is this really worth it
um
being watched is I would rather them be
there than doing it like
right I can relate to the voyeur part of
it the watching part of it so like I
would love okay this is the only way I
can be unicorn if like I know a really
established couple that I find in the
business established in the business
yeah if I find the girl and the guy
attractive and they're just looking for
someone to watch him I'm the Watcher I'm
the girl to ask like I love what oh I
would I would walk to people
all day I'd be like my request is that
okay in fact in fact this I will not
make out with any of them engage
sexually but I kind of just want to be
like the help I don't need to help I
would sit right there yeah I will watch
I'll watch anyone have sex yeah I'll
watch literally anyone okay same thank
you this is really relieving for me to
know I thought I was like there's
something wrong because I I always oh no
there's something wrong with all of us
that's yeah that's all we're all we
found each other very [__] up that's
why we have a podcast together and
people watch it because we're strange
okay here's what the polyamor the third
one whatever okay this guy sent in I was
in a polyamory for eight months and the
third only said she loved my wife in
more of a platonic way but only to me so
he confided in her sh the third told him
that she doesn't love the wife more than
platonically she was really only in it
for me as we had flirted for a few
months before my wife sought her out
after she saw a spice science story she
put up and asked me do you want to [__]
if I wrote those eight months as a
script it would be a hit Netflix show
but everyone would hate us for our flaws
well that's so that's why I think any
Trio like sexually that's so sketchy
because look they're already these two
are can I just say I I'm only into
platonically
is this threesome
I kind of knew I feel like the only way
that would work is if there was like a
girl code the girl girls would have to
almost like each other a little bit more
than they like the guy and she
approached him first like that's a
little sauce I don't like that yeah wait
here's another I guess we're just in
Gossip corner is that okay yep because
people are just sending stuff I have
juicy gossip basically one of my
brother's friends girlfriends who I
don't really like told me that she went
to a friend's Bachelorette and they all
changed in the bride's house in her room
and weeks later the bride found women's
underwear and no one claimed them
brothers friend's girlfriend said she
claimed they were hers to make her feel
better like she stirred up and lied and
the now husband is cheating and she's
just not gonna say anything wait I don't
understand okay so they were all they
went to this girl's house yeah into her
room they all changed and then this girl
found underwear and it wasn't anyone's
underwear so it was from another time
with another girl but the girl just like
lied and said it was hers
but that's not taking one for the team
yeah it's kind of not
I mean maybe this girl's annoying and
she didn't want to hear her complain
about her cheating husband or something
maybe it was for herself it was just he
was like I don't want to deal with this
we know I know it's it that's weird yeah
this one is more trash Tuesday like I
had sex with my husband in our bed with
the windows open and saw a guy standing
in front of his garage across the street
clearly watching and trying to be sneaky
I said nothing and let him watch cute
yeah that's something but you live there
too so enjoy that for the rest of your
life right but I'm also so down for that
kind of yeah I don't know
um I love hearing people have sex
um the next remover at a hotel yeah
nothing turns me on yeah hearing it or
having it hearing having it hearing it
like if I hear them like oh they're
[__]
um like yeah that's one of the perks of
a hotel auditory right like you get to
imagine anything you want in your head
now you just get the
the the the audio of it so I have a
question so there's a guy in my
apartment complex who
trains people in his garage and his
garage is two garages away from mine and
Todd's office looks directly into it and
I'm always like my trainer's always like
out of town and stuff so I'm always
every time I see him I'm like how much
do you try you know I'm like and I never
go with him because I was like well I
was talking to Todd I was like I think
it's like hot for Todd to be like
looking down on me while I'm getting
trained by another guy
and then that's one and then two it's
just the convenience of it it's like
right there yeah but then Todd's like
yeah but when you don't want to work out
with him it's right there
like you're not gonna have to avoid him
when you no longer that is so solid of a
point like so it's so true you have to
be so careful about like any kind of
relationships of any type like with your
neighbors or anything that will ruin
your piece yeah ruin your comfort and
peace in your own home yeah like my
neighbor is like a famous
blogger in a different country like
she's like in whatever but she lives
next to me a lot of a lot of blogs about
a an annoying girl well like he upside
down pineapple lady no no it's someone
else but like and she's just like
gorgeous whatever she's like this
gorgeous blonde Swedish woman and I've
always fantasized about like oh my God
like the gorgeous blonde next door like
we should be friends but I'm like no I
don't want I don't want her to know who
I am I don't want any social media
anything because I just it's like so
scary like how that could go wrong well
Todd's like that because I'm so chatty
with everyone Tad's like we have to in
this new place like not do this because
it can just backfires like you want it
to just be like a and that way these new
neighbors move in
and you know I got a little friendly
there's a little bit it was the cluster
headache time so I was at home just kind
of like uh you know
and um they moved in and then
I thought this would be my nightmare
like three months after they moved in
the guy was like Hey I just didn't want
to be weird but I'm like a big fan of
yours and now I'm like I'm into it I
like it what what do you like about it
just they get you know
to live next to the star and happy for
them
but I've been starting to get like
recognized and I was like because before
I was like I really was like I don't
want people to like know know me or
whatever but
there's nothing I can do about it I live
in an apartment I was locked out of my
place a couple weeks ago and
um my neighbor thought it was suspicious
at first so he was like oh can I help
you I'm like yeah no I live here
and then because I was just like it's a
good brown girl daddy you know yeah I
got brown girl look at this cat burglar
this hot cat burglar yeah but he was
brown too and he's like are you okay I'm
like I'm fine I'm just waiting for the
locksmith but then he brought out beers
for me he was like here have this water
he brought a simply Spike Peach I was
like thank you so much it was really
sweet
um but I think that was like as
neighborly you know that's if you banged
him that's the problem I feel like
hooked up they're like oh God have you
ever hooked up with a neighbor never
that's and in fact when I hear that I'm
just like that sounds like such a crazy
like hot person's life that I don't have
yeah I've never either have you
like my neighbor when I was a kid that
was the best though oh my God I was so
obsessed with him wait really he was so
hot and we were just like
yeah we would just like hook up like he
it was his dad's house so he was there
every other weekend and I would just be
like it's funny until my parents sold
the house even though it was like years
later I would always look at his house
to see if the lights were on to see if
he was there because I was so into him
did that ever become like a problem like
a backfire situation
maybe for him he hooked up with one of
my friends oh I hurt my feelings that's
a big backfire and how did you did you
like see them
yeah I was at my he met her through me
I was like oh we hook up but I never was
willing to like
like piss on my men I was always like so
afraid of like being like
you're mine I want you to be my guy like
and then have them say no so I would
always be like whatever it's fine and
then I was like oh
it's hard but he'd walk by like I'd Tink
on the window with a knife
his dad was like are you being serious
like no I'm just [__] with him his
dad was like is your daughter like
threading my son no he's still my friend
he tried to pull the thing with me
though more recently where once I was
like with Todd and like definitely like
this is my guy he was like oh I always
thought we'd like I'm like you were sure
to be in high school dude he's like yeah
but I thought we'd just like always end
up together I'm like no
nice try we will say that it's like what
does it even mean how do you even know
um so I follow a lot of like medical
journals and sometimes like they tweet
out like just an image of something and
they were like guess the diagnosis you
just like guess or whatever but last
week I came across something I'd never
seen before usually sometimes there's an
extra other people's faces in it is it
like you could you're like oh my God I
know her yeah but then it's the craziest
stuff right it's usually like more like
rare stuff but I came across
um this thing called
um oral hair leukoplakia and I well I I
thought of you but I was like why why I
like a green hairy tongue oh and I
thought
oh my God yours is not just when you
think yours is bad like it could be
worse so like know that there are a
little bit hairy tongues out of there
you love it my tongue it's be it speaks
its own language it's a you gave
yourself a little lisp when you said
that too it's an expressive tongue I
don't know people like to talk about the
colors that it holds
um
specifically Rick gives me a hard time
about my of your tie-dye tongue yeah
um
I like that there's like a Wordle for
like like nerd nurses
yeah yeah I guess is it a competition no
it's not because like I don't I I don't
know 99. you only get like Five Guys
this stuff on there because they just
give you a picture and then you see all
the doctors like you're putting in their
guesses like I'm not a doctor but I like
to learn like what they are especially
if they're like super rare things is
there a cure for a hairy Green Tongue
yeah it probably has to asking for a
co-host
I I assume it's something you know
um like candida related
you know like someone who's like
immunized language like immunosuppressed
yeah
actually do have a question in medical
Corner which is
lately I've been having like a metallic
taste in my mouth what is that about
anything are you on awesome are you
taking Lunesta or any type of sleep aids
no but I did kind of like mess up a
little bit with my Lexapro and I kind of
missed a few days more than I should
have you're like tasting regular again
do things just do taste metal and then I
got back on it is that probably what's
causing it
this definitely wasn't the picture the
one I saw was really hairy
um I don't know Esther there's a lot of
things that cause a metallic taste in
your mouth really a lot of times it is
medications though so should I how
worried should I be not too worried okay
get your Alexa Pro you know dosage I'm
not
wanting to see this
hairy tongues Annie do you have any
symptoms you want to run by kalila while
we have her because I am not the correct
I'm not the person but go ahead and
I don't have any current symptoms but I
think I've brought this up to you before
when I would eat a lot of pastries my
discharge was bleaching my underwear and
bleaching holes in it oh my God that's
so interesting it was getting acidic
this was when I was living in Brooklyn
and I I it was the only thing I changed
because I've always kind of had a pretty
healthy diet but I had I had just
decided okay in the morning I do eat
sugary pastries
and then when I started doing it my
underwear was getting like I thought
something was happening in the wash and
then I realized it was my discharge was
so acidic that it was bleaching oh my
God that is so wild but and then when I
stopped doing the pastries it stopped
happening did your pastries were they
good and did your [__] get like
bleach from it too never unfortunately I
was still in full black face
you know I just it actually looks a lot
like that tongue funny you should say
um I just saw a video you know like I
went through my spank bank and um
there's a video of me in like reverse
cowgirl and my God is my [__] dog you
guys like there is no like I mean it's
beautiful like I'm a brown girl of
course my [__] is dark but like I
don't know if you have to be brown oh
yeah
I think actually that's an advantage you
have that it looks more it's like yeah
it ombres in a little
contrast on
[Laughter]
them it's just you know
sometimes I'd give it my hair a little
fade back there to kind of blend it
um well I shouldn't talk about this I
keep talking about my [__] every
episode I have a question for you guys
based on what kalila said last episode
you said something that you don't like
possessive uh men so it's uh all that
um 50 Shades of Gray
um mythology that all Every Woman was
obsessed with it is that a a fake
fantasy yeah that's real he was not
really possessive as much as he wanted
to like engage in some type of like BDSM
stuff right it's like dumb but it's but
it's almost like role playing like he's
not actually monitoring like that's how
you say monitoring
yeah he's not monitoring like her
whereabouts who she's friends with
whether or not she picks up the phone oh
my God somebody loves it
like
so like basically like she was under his
total control yes okay surrender
yourself to me is the premise wait but
that's like a thing
for like three hours but beyond that
well you guys all know the story of what
happened when I told Dave to do that I
ended up crying
because wasn't he he asked her to eat
something yeah we went to Vegas and I
was like You Take Control order the food
and then he did and then he ordered
octopus and was like eat it and I
started crying and we had to stop
immediately and he tried to break up
with you and then your little tentacle
came out
can I tell you a story what uh oh
get ready Austin wait did I already talk
about
um me being an octopus killer no so like
I have I've always had like a philosophy
because I find octopus
just really intelligent like their eyes
are really cool that's why I don't watch
them it's really complex I watch the
octopus teacher so like you know I've
been able to shoot fish and I feel like
pretty sad but I went out diving with
someone recently and I've always I've
always seen octopus and I don't
I don't collect them
she's gonna hurt you I want to keep
eating it oh oh yeah yeah then you like
the story you will love the story no but
I you already said the thing about
what the octopus oh you're fine look
yeah you're right it's Seafood you're
never gonna stop no love so like I'm
kind of a hypocrite in that I I will
shoot fish but then there's some animals
like I just don't want to touch and I
want to keep leave them alone one of
that is octopus but I went with a really
good diver
um um the last time and he's kind of
like an OG and he was like Hey you see
that right there and he was pointing at
an octopus and we were we've been out
for five hours in the water I was tired
and I didn't have it in me to be like
well my philosophy around octopus you
know I didn't want to be that girl it
was the first time I was diving with
them I really all still have pikmi in us
okay yeah I was old I was Hardcore with
me and I was like I'm not gonna this guy
took me out he doesn't know me I want to
like earn my [__] stripes or whatever
so I got the octopus and he was like
okay like to kill him you just have to
crunch on find their eyeball and like in
the water just kind of you know crunch
on their head and their eye and kill
them and then they turn white
and you think because I like eating it I
would like to hear that
you're not too that day and they were
delicious I feel like Vanessa would do
that Todd's mom would be like
oh yeah but you do that and then oh my
God the
amount of like I filled up my mask with
tears like I obviously didn't show him I
was like yeah no problem here and then I
put in the [__] and then I turned
around and I just started bawling in the
water because you know it was doing like
algebra when he did that it was doing it
how smart are they how how big was it it
was about Esther's eyes it was you know
and and you put the head in your mouth
and killed it with your teeth like this
and it hurt me but then I was like I
think that's did you eat it I was being
such a pygmy of course yeah all right
I'm just gonna kill it just to kill it
no like you boil it in beer to soften it
to get you to make to kill me a lobster
and when it's allowed to season October
you just have to ask me every day this
was a really cold winter and high
[__] maintenance
give it to me [__] you guys like the
texture of octopus is the most scariest
yuckiest thing to me what and I can eat
scallops I'm like cool you know you're
talking to a Spanish man like pulpo in
like the north of Spain is literally the
most delicious thing you will ever taste
if there are slugs out there that our
team can't eat octopus please have you
ever eaten escargot snails no
good we'll have an Esther escargot
octopus day we will not that I will put
my foot down I don't care you're all
right you're off the show against one
Esther does this not look good to you
are you the pool
bro it's butter and garlic bro Esther
this
I'm like
we need wreck now
Rick just comes from the ceiling
bro no where did this come from I don't
know probably just we're having a loopy
can I just say I'm too comfortable I
don't want to out that we've been
together for a long time today but this
happened post lunch something happened
barbecue sauce the barbecue sauce yeah
it turns you bro I got comfortable I
this is how I talk
three hours into a hangout
okay bro
but my my friends and I use bro but it's
in an accident goes my bro like we do
that
I like that Russian as always will we
it's supposed to be it's my Armenian
friend started it but we all call each
other my bro I take Esther Morris like a
Hebrew you know
[Music]
um it's like yeah who are just like
which person in here are you trying to
impress with the bro no literally who
would I possibly be trying to impress in
this room fancy Pete I don't know true
you got me there the new guy
Richie your barbecue sauce what what
dream I use them as an example sorry
Richie wait I had this is gonna it's
gonna change shift the the mood a little
bit wait can I tell you guys something
yeah yeah okay so I FaceTime Todd's
parents for
um
Fourth of July and Todd was in the other
room
and um
I was like talking to them and it was
great and I got my time with both of
them and I was like all right bye and I
forgot that they're not my parents and I
forgot to bring Todd the phone to even
talk to him
really I love them so much
I love them I was like oh my God I had
to call them back and bring them over
there I was like I've fully taken you
guys what did you guys talk about we
talk about all stuff I don't know
I love his his parents are the best
they're so awesome I will say there is
something fun especially for people like
our personality types where we like are
kind of a little baby we love parents
like about having a new set of parents
so you could kind of like show off for
and I just love that I love like Dave's
parents are proud of me you know I love
that feeling it's just they're so good
my favorite thing also is to tattle on
Dave I'll be like well he did this and
like yeah you know I'm trying to get him
to do this and if that's my favorite me
and Todd's mom could be like Todd's got
fat I'll grab his stuff she's like show
me
and like earlier in our relationship
like Dave would like randomly want to
have a cigarette and I'd be like I'll
tell your mom and he'd be like No And so
then but now I will say if you wanted to
I would be chill about it and then Kate
my
Todd's older brother's wife is a slug
and then his younger brother and her
wife like watch all of the all the
podcasts everything that's awesome okay
it's like a slug slug yeah oh my God
wait do you know what is so it's blowing
my mind is my niece is 15.
isn't that weird yeah I have a 15 year
old niece well because my baby niece
just turned 11 my first niece and so
she's very close to that it's gonna just
happen like that wait should our nieces
do the next trash Tuesday wait the niece
Edition yeah Jules Rudy is yeah foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'll also do three more episodes tonight
like let's go you're a different kind of
last today should we do another one
after this the barbecue sauce has gone
to her head bro bro
this is waffles rule this is a waffles
rule oh no I actually agree it's a
waffles rule where it's like you're not
aware of what but do you guys understand
that the nieces Edition
I brought my nieces to those Studio
and it's like there's like barbed wire
like the outside of the studio is not
cute but the inside is my nieces go
Auntie are we in prison it was so funny
they felt endangered
wait Esther I I can press an article
that I think you wrote okay way to put
me on the last is it like hey bro let me
tell you about how waffles rule
but it's it's an article called the case
against travel and basically it talks
about why do we travel do we think we
become Changed by the experience do we
travel because we want to be seen as
someone who travels basically this this
writer is like
you know like people who travel are full
of [__] and it's like
I like this yeah like you seek out new
experiences you wouldn't normally seek
out if you were home like for example
she talks about someone wanting to go
see like a certain type of Falcon like a
falconry and like like Abu Dhabi or
something like that and they're like why
are you doing this why are you seeking
out this thing you wouldn't normally do
why are you trying to not be yourself
right now okay I have a hot take here
maybe you're trying to escape yourself
I actually think that
there is so much travel bragging on
Instagram that especially in the
summertime like it has become this like
Cesspool of people
flexing they travel and I'm [__] over
it I'm done like if you if you are cool
take a trip and don't post about it like
and I love posting I love Instagram I
love social media but it's so much Flex
culture showing off like or what if
someone's looking at that and they go oh
my God that place is so beautiful I'd
love to have my wedding there okay I'm
so glad that person posted that picture
that's
possible travel turns us into the worst
version of ourselves while convincing us
we're at our best well Esther stays the
same worst part of herself
pastor does not change at all except
that one trip you went on where did you
go to Italy Italy with the hockey and I
was like this is so she's so fake I was
like Esther posing and stuff and I was
like Esther's next to a statue
what did these girls slip in her drink
just hot girl stuff I I guess like when
I've traveled it's usually been because
like I'm dating a boy there and I
usually stay like a whole month so it's
not as short-term
um but I do think you're right about
like the whole influencer culture of
just getting the whatever it is for the
gram that they need whatever backdrop
they need and then not even like
immersing themselves in like anything
about like the country not learning
anything but I will say if that is your
passion and what I know I'm gonna kind
of like contradict what I said slightly
if you are traveling and you are getting
the photo you're getting the shot and
it's like this creative cool expression
you like taking the pictures you like
whatever your outfit's like that is
different and I do respect that and I
think that's cool I've seen people do
that and rock that and I'm like oh I I
wish I was that but when it's just like
no when you when they rock that do you
mean like they're like
[Applause]
but like you guys know what I'm talking
about where it's just like flexing
okay I'm gonna counter what you're
saying just because
let's just let people flex and see what
the culture is now this is like how
people are making their money the
algorithm's weird people are like
desperate just let people like get their
hustle on and do what they need to do I
also believe in that okay but wait segue
into have you guys heard that like this
is so like naughty to bring up but that
basically like a lot of influencers who
are just absolutely gorgeous who are
always traveling like are confirmed like
escorts in Dubai and like apparently
it's not just like normal escorting but
they they do like really nasty stuff
like what I don't know what I wanted
escort tourism yeah what do you mean
what kind of nasty stuff I don't know I
was hoping you would know no look okay
so she does bro
um my bro let me tell you
um I don't know about like you know the
Middle East or whatever but I can't and
say this about very affluent businessmen
in the Philippines they do still and
they still use this term concubines and
so I don't know about the actual sex
that goes on how crazy it is wild or
whatever but a lot of these girls are
balling out of control they have
Mansions they're usually like the third
or fourth like concubine and they are
not allowed okay the rules are this
usually from the people that I know
they're not allowed to get pregnant by
another man they are allowed to have
boyfriends but they're not allowed to be
public with that boyfriend
um but they have everything they have
jet skis they they're like balling out
of control
they got that jet ski [__] yeah so I
don't know if that's the same as like
you know escort tourism but I know that
there are girls who are lifelong escorts
who are living living amazing lives
amazing lives
that sounds so and they don't even
really need like most of these men are
married so they maybe like have to have
sex with them just sometimes it's very
part-time it sounds like yes
lots of Benefits full medical well okay
also on the Travel thing like like to
can you're saying yeah yeah can is like
that's I feel like every hot girl who
isn't like an established model is
probably that right yeah I guess that's
why I've never been invited
I don't want to bring your cans to
Canada
the travel thing though like
don't you feel a little bit fatigued by
like people almost their whole
personality is vacationing in Italy for
the summer
I think some people just like to travel
though that's like you don't like it at
particular that much I believe that some
people like it but I also believe that
there like this article says there's a
case against it
some people make it their entire
identity right like that's just what
they do
um like they're in Hawaii all the time
it's almost like I wish I could counter
and say that I live there but like I
can't even yeah
I live there why don't you like
traveling Mr
um
first of all we travel for work and so
we do travel that makes being home feel
like extra special and good I will say
when I did go to Italy with my friends
like that was fun and I understood it
I can like it but I also I'm not going
to become a new different fake person
when I'm traveling and so I've learned
I'm still gonna be regular old news yeah
sitting in your room I'm still me I'm
not I don't really go by the fantasy of
like oh when I'm in a new place I'm a
whole new person Sometimes some look
sometimes there is that and it's great
and it is amazing and it's so valuable
but I feel like we almost overestimate
the importance of travel these days like
I really do I I think it's great I think
it's expanding for your mind and look if
you love it if you can afford it you
should do it but I do think not everyone
can afford it and it's not like you're
not living an amazing life if you can't
travel I really I think that we travel
for work is a big thing and then I think
that there is when you go on vacation
there is like
a hustle sometimes there isn't all these
things and you're like I am not relaxing
right like if I'm a person that when I'm
in LA and it's a day off I can maybe
accomplish one thing why then on a
vacation how am I gonna do four
sightseeing things like that you're
tired you're like the yeah I'm hot I'm
hungry I can't find a coffee shop with
the right almond milk like
almond it's all it's always changing
it's always changing sometimes it's
whole milk bro can you not yell at me
bro bro can you take it down I know I
triggered you I talked about milks
bro we're already we're talking about
Tommy that's already touching for you
a beautiful vacation
um God forbid
the best was just when she went to Japan
and I there was a joy when you broke
your toe there was a joy you had I do
need to go like I told Dave like we need
I did not go to Japan but I really want
to go to Japan Todd and I have that on
our list Todd just got his passport so
now I feel like I really want to take
him places but Todd's not really that
into traveling either he's not like
you know what else you know what else
I go on vacation I don't feel the magic
I don't feel changed and then I'm like
is there something wrong with me
just look at yourself and then I feel
like take a mirror with you
like I don't see what everyone else is
seeing it it makes me think of the
career enthusiasm where Larry David is
looking at the ocean he's like I don't
get it yeah
years to get into the ocean yeah it's
taken me so long I was just like there's
sand it's hot I'm wet and hot and
there's traffic to get here like there's
so much friction in any kind of travel
or experience it's sometimes
a movie with some popcorn and a soda
sitting at home playing cards you can't
quite beat those what card games are we
playing here go fish oh no oh no Dave is
teaching me how to play poker we should
learn because Todd plays poker all the
time I'm learning let's go I want to
play with [__] um Jennifer Tilly okay
wait I don't think we're ready to go pro
you guys did not care when I brought
that up and it was upsetting to me
absolutely I love her you swung by the
topic I was like
I Will Wait Dave was apparently when we
were in Vegas he was playing does he go
to Hustler
I think so he goes to I think so but he
so we were in Vegas and I'm gonna look
up this girl
um that he was playing with
and I'm like should we get her on the
podcast she's a professional first of
all she's hot and I was like what the
[__] Dave
she's a profession Andrea botes is that
her
yes she's a professional chess player
and she's into poker and she's hot
dude Todd's always like you would suck
at poker which makes me want to be good
at it oh my God she's so pretty
[__] Dave
see this is what threatens me a girl who
can play chess he doesn't care yes I
know that's what everybody's thinking
[Laughter]
look at how good her chest is
I saw this thing you're technically good
at chest
[Laughter]
this girl asked this question on Tick
Tock um that said what unserious
generational curse are you breaking in
her example like basically like what
your parents did not allow you to do or
what your parents did that you would
never impose on your children anymore
like for example like for me I don't
think I'm gonna force my kids to finish
the food on their plate if they're full
they're full my parents did not allow me
to like leave a morsel right we never
left more so there was never most left
we were piggy piggy piggy pigs they
never had to worry about that
I wasn't allowed to dress myself like I
would for sure allow my kids to dress
themselves I am not going to have a
little [__] dress kid not a [__]
chance I was a little baby [__] and my
kid is going to be after I'm not gonna
like force them but I'm gonna I'm gonna
guide them to not dress like a hoe how
do we do that you guys we know too much
we've been molested it's like we know
too much we know it's not about oh that
like no matter what you do
it's all going to be a problem
like we're gonna [__] up our kid this
different ways that we were [__] up
like so I'm kind of like I love how
we're just saying we're gonna have kids
now because Whitney
I already said I would get Knocked Up by
whoever [__] me first I just got so
unfair to say that you know what you
should do you should have them all do
the Okie cookie and then you just shove
them where they jerk off on the cookie
what what is the Okay cookie you can't
just gloss or you just swing by it like
I just really over the guy's just being
so like you cannot Jennifer Tilly though
um guys will jerk off in a circle onto a
cookie where has this been a thing like
summer camp Oh Annie hold on I'm not
looking it up
you jerk off into a cookie
they would jerk off in a circle into a
cookie do you eat the cookie or you I
don't know I was never there I've just
only been the cookies
okay and then what happens how do I do
this so they they jerk off and then you
shove the cookie up so then you don't
know who the dad is it's just survival
of the the fittest chip chocolate chip
that's kind of a really cool competition
I think I think the the cookie is uh the
last one to finish has to eat the
cookies it has to eat the cookie oh
that's what it is you don't Chuck off
onto it you jerk off onto it but the
last person you think
I thought there's not even a blinking
cursor wow
the fact that you didn't have to look
this up
I've heard of it
yeah listen if you want to be a bro
[__] you need to learn
you just blew it your first protest
you got an F we I do we're fake so
triggered when my guy friends are like
oh I guess you're not and you can't
handle guy talk I'm like no I'll do it
I'll do anything to be a part of guy
talk I want to be a guy but not like
that you know
[Laughter]
vacations too hard are we doing Russian
Roulette sperm this summer
koyla wait it's only Russian men okay
maybe let's get you pregnant we'll take
you out okay we'll get you pregnant okay
baister be turkey based me and you know
what don't even tell me whose sperm it
is mystery cookie just mix it up whoever
just collect mix it up and then we'll
see I'll just tell you some one thing
it's gonna have half of a green hairy
top
if I have my say
have you guys heard of a grandparents
Derby
people are another thing Esther's going
to be have foma which wasn't invited
what the greatest Derby and Esther
wasn't involved like if my dad was alive
I feel like he would be a part of this
but you make them run it's like yeah oh
my God it really is that yes watch it's
like my dad would do this I know he
would but it's basically just a
geriatric
you know just running the hundred yard
dash I don't want to be betting on
people hurting their hips you know I
mean more than just hurting I mean it's
probably bad and once you break that
head things yeah faster here we go okay
Helen you missed the face plant yeah
rewind just a little bit yeah this is
really smart because we stay active and
why does she have a purse on
I always tell my parents that's not fair
look at that one guy was like so much
they was really you just stay
able-bodied because if they're not
useful oh
not one woman does not look that old
yeah do people bad
I mean would you bet on your own parents
I mean I maybe would I would better my
dad my dad is not allowed to run okay no
running dad oh Corgi
oh I miss Randy
[Laughter]
yeah
I'm having a crash from the barbecue
chicken salad you were so high remember
I just want everyone to know that she
said she could do five more episodes
I cannot have snacks oh my God that was
so scary don't throw it you've survived
it and it didn't argue it did hurt
oh sorry I'm not assisting I swear you
guys thank you so much
give me that's my banana give it back
I'm setting a boundary give me my banana
I I have a boundary that I have to throw
another banana at you one more come on
oh my God no she has to do it in threes
everybody knows the rule of three if you
don't do it something bad is gonna
happen yeah it's bad luck on vacations
I'm perfect at being an older you guys
are such older sisters then you should
listen to me [__]
well I'm trying to end it you guys thank
you so much
I love your effort today
hey bro
I'm Gonna Get You she's really browing
down
thanks Bros bros thank you so much as
you roll um click the subscription link
or what is it the little bell click the
Bell click the Bell
um and we will see you next week eat
your potassium
[__] bro bro bye Bros
oh
[Music]